it's biography of 17th century explorer
naturalist and Buccaneer William Dampier
this week's public lives feature is an
hour well thank you very much indeed for
that very kind introduction and I'd like
to say that it's both a pleasure and a
privilege to be here with you this
evening
what I'd like to do over the next hour
or so is to tell you about an explorer
who combined a day job as a pirate and
as a privateer with a passionate indeed
pioneering interest in science and
nature and I'd like to take you back in
time I invite you to picture the scene
as one day in September 1683 in the Cape
Verde Islands off the west coast of
Africa William Dampier we see here was
lying obscured among the scrubby
vegetation he was doing a bit of
bird-watching and he was excited he had
just caught his first sight of flamingos
and the detail the delicacy of his
descriptions would I think gladden any
more modern ornithologist the flamingos
were he wrote much like a heron in shape
though bigger and of a reddish color and
in such numbers that from a distance
they appeared like a brick wall their
feathers being of the color of new red
brick they nested in shallow ponds where
there is much mud which they scraped
together making little hillocks like
small islands where they leave a small
hollow pit to lay their eggs they never
lay more than two eggs and the young
ones are at first of a light gray but
then as a practical and hungry 17th
century sailor and to the probable
revulsion of any ornithologist Dampier
noted the
it's culinary qualities the flesh is
lean and black yet very good meat you
wrote their tongues have a large knob of
fat at the root which is an excellent
bit a dish of flamingos tongues being
fit for a Prince's table Dampier was
also observing the movements of the
tides the currents and the winds around
the islands meticulously recording all
this data in his journal and he would
later use this information to draw
far-reaching conclusions about their
behavior and about the relationships
between them however he would fail to
mention that while he was deep in all
these worthy scientific observations his
companions just around the corner in the
next Bay were otherwise engaged plotting
to seize a better ship for the piratical
voyage to the South Seas on which they
and Dampier were bound and in this slide
here we have a depiction of how a
Buccaneer fleet might have looked around
this time but I bring you those scenes
because I think they highlight the
contradictions in the career and in the
character of William Dampier his
portrait in London's National Portrait
Gallery shows us as we see here a lean
strong featured man he's got brown
shoulder length hair he's wearing a
plain coat and he's holding a book in
his hand as you can see the spine of the
book is being held out towards the
onlooker and the portrait is called it
is styled pirate and hydrographer but
even that really tells us only part of
his story he was a pioneering navigator
he was a naturalist a travel writer an
explorer as well as an eye drog refer
who was indeed perfectly happy to seek
his fortune as a part
he was born in 1651 in Somerset in the
West Country of England here you can see
his birthplace in the village of east
khoka we know that in his early years
William Dampier was an adventurer
fighting with a Spanish sorry fighting
with the Buccaneers preying on the ships
and towns and villages of the Spanish
mane inspired with what another
Buccaneer called that sacred hunger of
gold he marched with a Buccaneer army
through dense humid snake and
spider-infested jungles and over the
Isthmus of Panama to plunder Spanish
ships and cities and here we have a
depiction dundas obviously at a later
David of showing what it might have
looked like as the Pirates took one of
these cities and using the favored
tactics of the Buccaneers we know that
he and his companions stealthily
approached the Spanish galleons in small
boats rowing up beneath the stones to
jam their rudders then they quickly
boarded their prey whose decks soon ran
red with gore the Buccaneers and here we
see a woodcut depicting a Buccaneer
around this time the Buccaneers caroused
they argued over the division of spoils
three pieces of eight the silver gold
and jewels the sumptuous fabrics silks
and Muslims and on one occasion as
Dampier recalled seven or eight tons of
marmalade of quince and a stately new
now Dampier could very well have been
hanged at London's execution dock and
his Tod corpse left to dangle as a
warning like that of this unfortunate
gentleman here
Captain Kidd but instead Dampier made a
transition which I like to think of us
from Captain Jack Sparrow in Pirates of
the Caribbean to the ship's doctor the
fighting naturalist Stephen Maturin in
mastering commander
Dampier became the first man to voyage
three times around the world recording
nature with passion even obsession the
books that he wrote based upon his
observations brought him from obscurity
to celebrity they changed scientific
perceptions and they really altered the
literary landscape dampier's
understanding and mapping of winds and
currents were pioneering James Cook
Horatio Nelson who we see here they
studied his methods they used his maps
over 70 years before Cooke Dampier was
the first Englishman to lead an
expedition to Australia and to document
its wildlife his work as a naturalist
influenced Charles Darwin and Alexander
von Humboldt who we see here in the
foreground with his colleague Baum floor
Darwin von Humboldt used amperes acute
observations his detailed descriptions
as building blocks for their theories
Humboldt admired the man whom he called
the remarkable English Buccaneer - whose
works he thought these subsequent
studies of great European scholars
naturalist and travelers had added
little and although born nearly a
century after dampier's death Charles
Darwin found dampier's work in his words
a mine of information
he felt so familiar with him that he
referred affectionately to old Dampier
in his diary damp years a discourse of
trade winds breezes storms seasons of
the year
tides and currents which was included in
his second book established his
reputation as an eye drog refer a
classic of its era it's in fact being
quoted ever since by scientists and
meteorologists but in dampier's day it's
remarkable perhaps how little was known
about harvesty moved in fact influential
and respected
suggested that the entire world's oceans
were regulated and saved from stagnation
only by the circulation of their water
through the Earth's center entering at
the North Pole and out through the South
or via gurgling subterranean passages
between seas such as under the Isthmus
of Panama between the Atlantic and the
Pacific Oceans as he tramped the Isthmus
with the Buccaneers Dampier pondered the
belief that the Isthmus was in his words
like an arched bridge under which the
tides make their constant courses as
duly as they do under London Bridge
which we see here as it looked in the
17th century
Dampier listened for the allegedly
continual and strange noises made by
those subterranean fluxes and refluxes
as he called them of course he heard
nothing of the kind
and he dismissed the possibility of such
passages in his discourse Dampier also
provided detailed information on tides
and he distinguished between tides and
currents he found that the currents
flowed further out from the shore they
were much more constant in their
direction of flow he identified that to
quote in all places where the trade wind
blows we find a current setting with the
wind
he then deduced that the winds were the
causes of occurrence the first time this
key connection had ever been made
pioneering Lee he described what
hydrographer now calls the monsoon
currents in the Indian Ocean they
Benguela current the North Brazil
current the Gulf Stream the Peru current
the southern end of the California
Current and the equatorial currents
around the world damp es description of
all these currents was essentially
correct and really a major advance in
hydrography and run this time we have
the astronomer Edmund Halley as well as
Dampier also investigating wind patterns
both men produced maps which became
landmarks in the early history of
scientific knowledge of prevailing winds
but damp years were the more accurate
they were the more complete Dampier
alone and for the first time created a
wind map of the world including the
Pacific a region of which Halle was
ignorant and here we have one of Dampier
specific wind maps so it was dampier's
maps not Halley's that became the
prototype for the many maps and globes
picturing the trade winds which appeared
throughout the 18th century another of
damp years innovation supposed to use
shade and arrows - in his words sure the
course of the shifting trade winds his
maps uniquely indicated the reversal of
the monsoons were in as he wrote rains
follow the Sun and begin on either side
of the Equator within a little while
after the Sun has crossed the equinoxes
and so continuous till after his return
back again
and since Dampier correctly associated
winds and currents his wind maps are
often regarded as giving the first
integrated picture of ocean current
flows in particular around the tropics
Dampier was an intensely rational man
very rational his descriptions of
natural phenomena after a storm he
noticed what he called a certain small
glittering light it was he said like a
star dancing around the top of the mast
he had seen this light before creeping
over the decks like a great glow worm
itch was sindell most fire an electrical
discharge which sometimes appears after
storms at sea but many of his
contemporaries believed it was a
manifestation of Christ or the Holy
Spirit it was often known as the corpus
Sant other sailors thought the radiant
light was the cavorting ha
goblins or fairies or to quote the
enchanted bodies of witches they even
believed that it it might signal the
spirit of a dead comrade come back to
warn them of a mortal danger but even
though he was writing at around the time
of the Salem witch trials
Dampier was convinced that it was a
natural phenomenon with a rational
explanation he disparaged what he called
ignorance see men with their dismal
stories about what it pretended Dampier
was also an instinctive intuitive
naturalist here we have one of the
drawings what he observed from one of
his books he really pioneers watches
today known as descriptive botany and
zoology later developed by Joseph Banks
the naturalist who sailed with Captain
James Cook and by descriptive botany
what I mean is the careful the details
the objective recording of the world's
living things and here I give you
dampier's precise description of this
creature an armadillo the armadillo he
wrote so-called from its suit of armor
is as big as a small sucking pig the
body of it pretty long this creature is
enclosed in a thick shell which bars all
its back and comes down on both sides
and meets under the belly leaving room
for the four legs the head is small with
a nose like a pig a pretty long neck and
it can put out its head before its body
or when it walks but on any danger she
puts it under the shell and drawing in
her feet she lies Stockstill like a land
turtle ie a tortoise and though you toss
her about she will not move herself
the shell is jointed in the middle of
the back so that she can turn the fore
part of her body about which way she
pleases the feet are like those of a
land turtle and it has strong claws
wherewith it digs holes in the ground
like a Coney but then
as a man who often had to live off the
land he added for others culinary
guidance but the flesh is very sweet and
tastes much like a land turtle when he
was in South Africa
Tapia gave us the first description in
English of this creature the zebra which
he described as a very beautiful sort of
wild ass its body
curiously striped with equal lists of
white and black the stripes coming from
the rich of his back
and ending under the belly which is
white these stripes are two or three
fingers broad running parallel with each
other and curiously intermixed we know
that new sights and suns and smells
consume Dampier he was one of the first
English speakers to record the effects
of Mariana writing some it keeps sleepy
some Mary putting them into a laughing
fit and others it makes mad another of
his discoveries in the South Pacific was
this the breadfruit Dampier wrote the
first description in English of his
handsome trees which were he said as big
and high as our largest apple trees with
their velocity dark green leaves and
fruits as big as a penny loaf he also
explored the process which metamorphosed
the fruits into bread writing the
natives of this island is it for bread
they gather it when full-grown while it
is green and hard then they bake it in
an oven which scorches the rind and
makes it black but they scrape off the
outside black crust and there remains a
tender thin crust and the inside is soft
tender and white like the crumb of a
penny loaf there is neither seed nor
stone in the inside but all is a pure
substance like bread this gentleman here
Captain Bligh
quoted dampier's glowing description in
his own book giving his side of the
mutiny on the bounty story as being the
catalyst for Britain's to see breadfruit
as suitable food for their slaves for
their indentured servants in their
American possessions and heads for the
ill-fated voyage of the bounty to Tahiti
to bring live specimens home dampier's
description of the avocado introduced
the fruit to the english-speaking world
this is how he described it the fruit is
as big as a large lemon it is of a green
color till it is ripe and then it is a
little yellowish they are seldom fit to
eat till they have been gathered two or
three days but then they become soft and
the skin or rind will peel off the
substance inside is soft as butter he
recommended eating it mashed with sugar
and lime juice to give it flavor and to
make it into a gourmet dish how else
with just a little salt and a roasted
plantain to satisfy hunger
Dampier also noted the belief that to
quote this fruit perverts to lust and is
therefore said to be much esteemed by
the Spaniards Dampier also described the
Sapodilla tree which was he said as big
as a large pear tree and with an
excellent fruit the juice of which was
white and clammy and will stick like
glue and of course it's the latex of a
severed yellow today which provides
cheek lay the basis for our chewing gum
Dampier also examined cochineal which at
that time was thought to be made from
seeds
however Dampier identified the real
source as a small insect infesting a
plant which resembled a prickly pear
Dampier watched the indians beat the
clock with sticks to drive the red
insects high into the air so that the
heat of the Sun killed them and they
fell down onto the large linen cloths
that they had spread on the ground they
left them to dry for several days then
scooped
them up to make what Dampier called the
much esteemed Scarlett but why the
interest in damn PS day in cochineal
well at this time cochineal was
particularly coveted by the restoration
lady for her toilette here we have the
famous portrait by Lily of nell gwyn
mistress of charles ii the restoration
lady had a truly formidable battery of
cosmetics at the time these included cat
dog mixed with vinegar as a depilatory
and Muskaan's cut into false eyebrows so
if you consider that cochineal was a
relatively innocuous part of her armoury
she applied it to her cheeks to give her
becoming flush on top of the white LED
compound ceruse as it was called which
women then used to create a delicate
overall pallor to hide the craters
caused by smallpox
what about damp year as a naturalist
well he was the first to visit all the
continents and to travel widely in areas
largely unknown to Europeans this meant
that he was able to compare and to
contrast animals birds reptiles and
plants for across the globe he was among
the first party of Britons to visit
these islands the Galapagos here his
scientific observations of marine green
turtles let him to write that they were
bastard green turtles compared to those
which he had seen in the Caribbean the
sea was suggesting location dependent
differences within species he was
prefiguring Darwin but this was a
revolution review it was a direct
variance with accepted religious
doctrine at that time scholars
calculated in years months and days the
date of creation when every living thing
had been created and since when no
change had taken place nor would until
the millennium and beyond the consensus
as Dada
in 1658 when Dampier was a boy was that
the six days of creation had begun at
9:00 a.m. on Monday 23rd of October 4004
BC but dampier's continuing deep
interest in relationships within and
between species later let him in a study
of brazilian waterfowl during a stay in
salvador de Bahia in Brazil here we can
see the Portuguese fought there this led
him to be the first to introduce
subspecies both as a word and as a
concept
the four types of long-legged fowls he
saw wading in the swamps were he decided
as near akin to each other as so many
subspecies of the same kind this
reference to subspecies was the first
public use of the term his view that
some types of animals and birds were
more closely related than others was
again formally heretical the accepted
doctrine was that each had being create
Lee each had been created in precisely
its present form and entirely
independently Charles Darwin we know
later regularly referred to dampier's
works during the voyage of the Beagle
and the famous red notebook in which
Dampier first formulated his theory of
natural selection quotes observations
from william dampier another Dampier
scientific firsts was his description of
migration patterns in his first book he
gave a detailed account of the migratory
patterns of the green turtle in the
Caribbean in the Atlantic and in the
Pacific a measure of how advanced was
his thinking about the principles of
migration and of how it worked in
practice is that in dampier's time
Daniel Defoe's old schoolmaster
seriously claimed in a pamphlet that
swallows migrated to the moon in winter
and eight years later we have the great
lexicographer Samuel Johnson maintaining
what was the still common thesis
swallows wintered under the ice in ponds
what about Dampier as an explorer well
he was the only major British maritime
explorer between this gentleman Francis
Drake and his fellow adventurers of the
16th and early 17th centuries and this
gentleman here James Cook and his fellow
naval expedition errs in the mid to late
18th century damp year uniquely bridge
those two eras fusing the piratical
plundering and derring-do of the former
with these scientific inquiry
the meticulous chart and record-keeping
of the latter damp year first visited
Australia with his fellow Buccaneers in
January 1688 they were the first English
speakers to reach the mainland and they
anchored in a deep Bay here in Kingsland
Pisco characater Bay northeast of the
modern town of Broome in Western
Australia here they spent two months in
the region recuperating and careening
and repairing their ship but they had
reached a land that was on the edge of
the then known world
Dampier wrote in his first book it is
not yet determined whether it is an
island or a main continent but I am
certain that it joins neither Asia
Africa nor America that day in January
1688 Dampier gazed on what he described
as low even land with sandy banks
against the sea and it looked to his
eyes and arid unforgiving sort of
landscape spying men walking along the
shore the Buccaneers eagerly dispatched
a canoe to barter for provisions but as
the canoe approached the beach the men
ran off they hid the frustrated
Buccaneers searched for them for three
days but found only the cooling ashes of
abandoned fires their search for fresh
water the thing that the Mariner always
wanted most also proved fruitless there
were no flow
stream's no tumbling Brooks there were
trees some of them as big as apple trees
but none bought fruit or berries a few
birds hopped about the branches and
among the thin Tufts and spindly grasses
but there was little sign of any animals
the only tracks were in dampier's words
the tread of a beast as big as a great
mastiff dog which were probably the
tracks of a dingo
the Buccaneers eventually encountered
some Aborigines but the men at once
threatened the Buccaneers with their
lances and with their swords their
lances were long straight sharpened
wooden poles while their swords were
pieces of wood shaped dampier thought
somewhat like a Cutlass so they were
curved probably boomerangs but we know
that neither the Buccaneers nor the
Aborigines seemed too impressed with
each other on this encounter some years
later
Dampier was to return to Australia this
time not as a Buccaneer but commanding
the first British Admiralty expedition
to Australia he was sailing in a naval v
Reiter that would have looked like this
a ship called the Roebuck and on one of
his landings Dampier described how a
white flowered shrub resembling some
fire was growing close to the shoreline
further inland here at Shark Bay in the
coarse reddish sandy soil he found great
Tufts of grass and there were several
trees and shrubs but none above ten feet
high
their leaves were whitish on one side
and green on the other most had in
dampier's words either blossoms or
berries red white yellow but mostly blue
which smelt very sweet and fragrant
there were also very small flowers
growing on the ground that were sweet
and beautiful and for the most part
unlike any I had seen elsewhere he was
correct in recognizing their uniqueness
nearly all these plants were then
entirely unknown to botanists and here
we have one of the drawings of
Australian botanical specimens from his
book now despite his ship being wrecked
on their return journey of Ascension
Island
Dampier brought back to England
specimens of several of these plants and
many others the first botanical
specimens from Australia they're still
preserved in Oxford University and when
we looked at them we found that some
such as the ruby red stirred P still
retain much of their colour
Dampier also explored New Guinea
discovering the large island of new
britain and here as on many occasions he
gave careful descriptions of the local
people for the first time in english
here we have a depiction of the
inhabitants of New Guinea from he wrote
were wearing ornaments of crab claws and
white shells stuck through their noses
their hair was cut in riches upon their
heads and like their faces and hands
spectacularly painted in another group
the men were finally protected with
feathers of diverse colors about their
heads but the women had no ornament
about them nor anything to cover their
nakedness but a bunch of small green
bars before and behind stuck under a
string which came around their waists
and they were balancing large baskets of
yams on their heads
Dampier eager as ever to make
comparisons from across his travels and
to understand the structures of the
lives he met recalled in his book this I
have observed among all the wild natives
I have known that they make their women
carry their burdens while the men walk
ahead without any other load than their
arms and ornaments dampier's
descriptions of foreign peoples are
still frequently quoted by ethnographers
and i think they're notable not just for
their accuracy but also for their
sympathy for example when he was
visiting China he was shocked by the
bound feet or the golden lilies as the
Chinese called them of the women he
recorded how their feet were swathe in
tight bandages from infancy in his words
to hinder them from growing since the
Chinese
esteem little feet as a great beauty
this was he wrote an unreasonable custom
which made the women in a manner lose
the use of their feet instead of being
able to move freely the women could only
stumble about their houses and presently
squat down being as it were confined to
sitting all the days of their lives and
Dampier wondered whether it was in his
words a stratagem of the men's to keep
the women from getting about Dampier we
know respected admired the Indians of
South and Central America all his books
portray them with sympathetic insight as
in his words a very harmless sort of
people kind to any strangers and even to
the Spaniards by whom they are so much
kept under that they are worse than
slaves this makes them very melancholy
and thoughtful sometimes when they are
imposed on by the Spanish beyond their
ability to bear they will march off hold
tongues men women and children the
Indians who lived in their own villages
were he thought like gentlemen in
comparison with those who lived degraded
lives on the edge of Spanish tongues
forced to what forced it to work by the
Spanish for little or no wages damned
pious inclination was to believe the
ways of his own country were best but I
think he was a patriot not a jingoistic
imperialist he did not see the white man
at the apex of a triangle of humanity
preordained to rule and exploit other
peoples as of divine right he saw no
reason why all races could not reach
comparable levels of attainment and he
believed that each could learn from the
other he also saw some virtue in the
state of nature compared to living in a
more sophisticated society subject to
arbitrary rule
Dampier believed in individual liberty
and the dictatorship failed both ruler
and ruled he despised Spanish colonial
rule
and the way it in his view degraded the
local people
he preferred free trade to imperialism
and believe that every man should be
free to develop his potential
Dampier reserved some of his strongest
criticisms for the lazy as he call them
who failed to do so he believed in the
application of the buccaneers democratic
code and the right of everyone to have a
say in the course of their lives he even
showed a touch of feminism for example
criticizing his colleagues for their
refusal to give a female pilot a chance
simply because she was a woman
Dampier was an inspired navigator
during his three circumnavigations he
pioneered many other sea passages for
those that came after him he pinpointed
the location of islands while giving
practical tips on the best approaches
through reefs tidal races and shows of
course he didn't have the sophisticated
navigational instruments that would
appear during the 18th century but even
with them the British Navy still used
amperes discourse well into the 20th
century in fact because of its accuracy
because of its attention to detail but I
think that perhaps now piers greatest
gift was to convey in words to his
fellow countrymen the frontiers which
were opening up around them damn piers
best-selling rollicking accounts of his
voyages aroused an enthusiasm for travel
writing which made it the most popular
form of secular literature for the next
quarter of a century and beyond they
really were the first modern travel
books the works of the learn age which
was the first literary magazine in
English recommended his books to the
sedentary traveller for the variety of
descriptions and the surprising news of
the incidents because like a modern
backpacker Dampier traveled out of
curiosity for its own sake not merely in
of commercial and political gain and
that came through in his writing
sometimes his curiosity and in
particular his interest in food got him
into trouble we know that while
traveling here in Vietnam with us his
only companion a guide who couldn't
speak English a famished Dampier spotted
a small tower ahead drawing nearer he
found crowds of people mostly men and
boys milling around the base and nearby
stalls were spread temptingly with meat
deciding this must be a market and the
flesh was for sale he plunged eagerly
into the crowd to inspect it he reckons
some 50 or 60 hogs had been cut up the
pork looked to quote very good meat
although the pieces were far too large
for him he grabbed a quarter and he
signed that he wanted a hunk off perhaps
two or three pans but the result was
unexpected
Dampier was immediately assaulted on all
sides by furious screening people his
clothes were ripped and someone snatched
his hat from his head his guide did what
he could to appease the angry muttering
crowd he managed to drag Dampier away
but men followed them shouting abuse and
threatening further violence
eventually the guide managed to quieten
them even to retrieve the crestfallen
travelers hat he then hurried Dampier
off as fast as possible however due to
his lack of English the guide was unable
to explain exactly what the problem had
been Dampier later discovered that was
it in fact Don was interrupted a funeral
feast and that the tar was the pyre
which was about to be burned as well as
being a sound recorder of facts Dampier
was sufficiently skilled to infuse and
infuse his readers with the excitement
that he felt more than a century later
we have Alexander von Humboldt still
calling him to quote the finest of all
travel writers and the poet Samuel
Taylor Coleridge he praised what he
called down
pS exquisite mind hence the title of our
book he advised contemporary travel
writers to read and to imitate him damn
pious writings inspired a rational
wonder at what he had seen and his
simple English his homely similes
connected the lives of his readers to a
new and broader world a hummingbird was
in dampier's words a pretty little
feathered creature no bigger than a
great overgrown wasp a poisoned blow
dart of which Dampier had considerable
experience what he said like a knitting
needle
Dampier was the first to compare the
vast expanse of the flat ocean to the
surface of the millpond so familiar to
English country dwellers when we were
researching and we looked into the
oxford english dictionary we were amazed
to find that Dampier can claim over a
thousand entries in the dictionary if
you take just the first three letters of
the alphabet you'll find that you gave
to the English language such words as
avocado barbecue breadfruit cashew and
chopsticks I think it's no surprise that
that all those are connected to one
other with food again shows the
preoccupation of a sailor of that time
Dampier was the first to write in
English about Southeast Asia describing
the taste the manufacture of soy sauce
and of what we now know as Thai fish
sauce and anyone like Michael myself
researching the places that Dampier
visited from the logwood settlements on
the Caribbean coast of Mexico to the
Chinese coast or to the Pacific Islands
they will often find him cited as the
earliest and frequently as the only
Authority for his period out of the
literary world of his time react to him
well of course it embraced him the
darest John even wrote I dined with mr.
peeps
where was captain Dampier who had been a
famous Buccaneer
Dampier really opened other writers eyes
to new possibilities in human experience
he primed their imaginations without
Dampier there might have been no Yahoo's
no Robinson Crusoe no man Friday Daniel
Defoe he studied dampier's voyages
including his accounts of his shipwreck
on the uninhabited ascension island and
his tales of his tattooed companion The
Painted Prince we see depicted here the
painter Prince Joe Lee and a foe also
looked at dampier's tales of a mosquito
Indian named William marooned for three
years on the Pacific island of Juan
Fernandez and Daniel Defoe looked at the
testimony of another maroon sailor the
Scottish sailor Alexander Selkirk here
we have a statue to him erected in
Scotland in his hometown of Fife Selkirk
here who was abandoned on that same
island of Juan Fernandez on one of the
voyages on which Dampier sailed and
rescued on another we know that
dampier's voyages also strongly
influenced Jonathan Swift if you look at
Gulliver's Travels which was published
in 1726 11 years after dampier's death
you'll find Gulliver actually referring
in the opening passages to my cousin
Dampier but what about the character the
personality of William Dampier one of
his companions called him self-conceited
but I think that perhaps he had reason
to be as we traveled in his footsteps
we became increasingly impressed with
the accuracy of his writing and
descriptions and the sheer dedication
the perseverance needed to make them an
example of the first is that when
visiting one of dampier's landing places
here in Shark Bay in Western Australia
we found that our boatman had never been
there before
however we gave him Dampier sketch map
down piers descriptions
and he located it easily and a walk-in
damn pious footsteps across the darién
Isthmus of Panama truly made us
appreciate his dedication our days here
in the Darien were really not unlike his
we had to avoid areas where Colombian
guerrillas were making incursions just
as Dampier had avoided the Spanish we
encountered poisonous snakes
we followed Indian guide through the
rainforest watching them make purchases
from the leaves of monsters to treat
cuts just as they had done in the 17th
century
we almost collapsed with heat exhaustion
we slithered down gritty thorny slopes
scratching ourselves and snagging our
clothes then we had to wait chest high
across fast flowing rivers like these
and from these experiences we learned
firsthand the difficulties of protecting
our nodes our damp notebooks became tall
never spattered with mud with blood with
insect repellent and though our time in
the jungle was limited and precious to
us we sometimes just felt too tired to
take any notes we were all more
impressed but while dodging Spanish
patrols
Dampier had found the time and the
energy to mix his ink to trim his quill
pen to scratch entries in his journal
and then to painstakingly preserve his
papers from water in a Stoppard hollow
bamboo tube we know that Dampier was
also a courageous man not only in battle
but in disregarding hardships to make
his observations one of his strongest
self criticisms was that he let an acute
part of dysentery prevent him from
noting in detail and eclipses of the Sun
and usually these are no perennial
problems of the traveler these ailments
meant little to him they were merely an
opportunity to try out the local cures
such as yogurt and to record the effects
once he even had himself buried up to
his neck in hot sand to try and cure a
fever it worked in dampier's case
although a few years later a similar
cure killed Vitus Bering the Russian
Explorer of Alaska I don't think that
pier would necessarily have been an easy
companion he was inclined to be critical
of others and he was certainly not an
easy man to be married to he left his
wife Judith after just a few months of
marriage he said to her I'm sorry my
dear I'm just going to Jamaica to do a
few months of trading he wasn't he
stayed away for 12 years he came back
after his first run the world
Odyssey and I've often tried to imagine
what their reunion might have been like
on his eventual return but perhaps
surprisingly there was a reunion perhaps
surprisingly they did stay together on
his final circumnavigation which Dampier
made as a government-sponsored privateer
this time he finally succeeded in
realizing what he called his golden
dreams he finally captured one of these
a Spanish treasure galleon so when after
covering more than 200-thousand sea
miles in his lifetime he died at home in
London in 1715 Dampier was not an
entirely poor man himself he had however
I think brought more riches to the human
understanding of the world around him
and with that thought I'll close and
hope that I've kindled your interest in
one of the world's most interesting but
often overlooked explorers William
Dampier thank you so much thank you
thank you very much indeed and I'll now
invite my partner-in-crime up here to
join me and we will do our very best to
answer any questions that anyone may
have gentleman right over at the back if
you can you tell us a little bit about
where you went some of your adventures
and retracing the steps here yes I mean
we do enjoy our travels and so a man in
a serial circumnavigation was a good
topic for us and the places I think
where we felt particularly close to down
here and I don't know whether Mike
agrees but sadly for me really going to
the incidence of Panama trekking through
that jungle going through that
experience really made me understand his
personality his perseverance and seeing
some of the places there that the
Buccaneers attacked the little
settlement in the middle of the jungle
of Santa Maria which was a non troppo
for Spanish gold judges who slither down
the same banks of the Buccaneers to see
where the fort stood to actually be able
to visualize it or really I think put us
in contact with him and I think the
other most moving place that I found was
to go to Western Australia this very
still remote part of the coastline to
the north of Perth and to sit there and
to talk with members of the Aboriginal
communities about what it first meant
for their people when the first
travellers began to arrive from the far
side of the world to talk about that
first interaction between Europeans and
the Aboriginal people of Australia to
spend time along that coastline
- I felt brought me very close to
Dampier one other thing we recently went
to New Guinea trekking around after him
when Dampier was in New Guinea
he found or was given a stone axe which
is in Cambridge University when we were
in New Guinea we saw people who fitted
some of the descriptions he gave we also
were given a stone ax which still
resembled the one that damn beard had
which was seen in Cambridge that said a
lot to us I think about it just one
other point that the village that stamp
here came from East cocoa in Somerset
it's very unchanged it's a very pretty
village of old stone houses batch
cottages and to actually go there to see
the rural landscape which nurtured
someone like this which produced that
sheer love of nature that was really
very touching we were able to walk the
same tracks the paths around the village
that Dampier walked we were able to see
now the great house belonging to the
local Squire who gave Dampier his first
chance to really go abroad the man is
said to him look you know you got to see
the world I've got a sugar plantation
I'll give you a job there you go that
you can visualize it all happening the
unfurling of that acute curiosity
driving curiosity in the young Dampier
so if anybody's interested in him and
you find yourself in England
please do go to East coker because it
will bring him right home to you mention
of East Kok of course brings up TS Eliot
whose poem on that topic
when dumped he was about nine TS Eliot's
relation who knew Dampier left for the
New World TS Eliot only came back once
but his ashes are in the church wall in
East khoka next or opposite rather to
the plaque to William Dampier so again
that struck a few chords of us I think
it's nice that he's coca has two famous
songs both literary Diana and Mike
you've talked about the noble aspects of
dampier's career as an explorer and
naturalist
how did dum how did he fit this in with
the buccaneering and the piracy and are
there any signs in in writings he left
of sort of moral schizophrenia or any
awareness of a contradiction between
higher purposes and lower motives one of
the things we did we were very lucky to
find was in the British Library and
Sloan it was a founder of the library
had bought up lots of pirate manuscripts
and amongst them we found the
draft of dampier's first book now in
that Dampier concentrated much more on
daring do and piratical bad deeds but we
also saw that when he was getting on
with getting towards publication not
only did he add a lot more scientific
information his descriptions of the
armadillo
he started modifying the descriptions of
poetical things crossings out here then
sort of descriptions like these were
piratical fellows I was with crossings
out was feeling slightly sorry about X&Y
very worried about the captain had
abandoned on an island and he then gave
a little apologia which he didn't
include in his book but you could see
there the man sort of thinking how much
can I say about this how much of this is
going to be best-seller because it's
good rollicking action against the
Spanish how this cut how much does this
cast me in a non too good light so that
was where we saw it we saw him trying to
balance what he was gonna say
speaking of piracy did he just take off
and become a pirate or did they have
letters of marque how did he get going
on all this what first brought him from
England to the Caribbean because this
other thing just now this chance to work
on a sugar plantation but it didn't
really accord with death years view of
how he wanted to spend his time because
when he got there he found he wasn't
actually in charge of things he was
expected to ladle me
the sugar syrup so he punched the
plantation manager went off traded for a
while spent time with the lockwood earth
in the Bay of Campeche in Mexico when
that didn't work out he found that there
was a big army of Buccaneers which was
massing at the time to walk over useless
for Panama to have a go at the Spanish
in their possession in their towns and
in their cities now these [ __ ] years
were you like pirates operating in the
Caribbean area and their position was a
little bit ambiguous it depended on the
state of politics back home in England
when England was formally at war with
Spain it's usually the English
government she only had a very small
Navy
she is those Buccaneers as a sort of
unofficial Navy to protect their
possessions in the Caribbean they're
part of the time that don't here was
with the Buccaneers he had a sort of
semi official sanction if you like part
of the time it was really a generic
piracy but later in his career
you mentioned the question of having
letters of marque well letters of marque
for what were given to you by your
government to establish you as a
respectable and official pirate what
happened was when England was formally
at war the government said to various
ships captains right here are your
letters of marque it's an official piece
of paper giving you carte blanche to
sail off into the wild blue yonder to
attack the ships of England's enemies to
take whatever is on board and we'd like
ten percent of the profits please that's
what a privateer was and that's what
deaf people came in the later stages of
his career so he moves from this
ambiguous picture of sometimes a pirate
sometimes just a Buccaneer to becoming a
more respectable privateer in later life
ginger got to amplifying
I think that's fine I mean he never took
an English ship as far as we know he
didn't want to take a Danish one which
was a specially an ally of England you
mentioned that he was a naturalist and
gave very good descriptions and that
those descriptions were very useful to
people dealing with natural selection
later on did he give any real hints as
to natural selection at all in what he
wrote it's use of when he was in the
Galapagos he compared the turtles in the
Galapagos in the Pacific and in the
Atlantic denominated the ones in
Galapagos bastard and basically doing
that also two other things he saw to
indicate there were differences between
the ones he'd seen there and the ones
elsewhere that's perhaps one indication
he also as I said for natural selection
picked up that on the subspecies sardana
said it's a location dependent species
etiquette education dependent
differences between species and the
concept of the subspecies and we know we
were very surprised first of all to come
across that how early it was but equally
we were surprised when we would
literally just glancing through the
Charles Darwin red notebooks we didn't
know the medallion references there but
to actually find so many references to
damn piers work and to this very simple
familiar attitude that Darwin seemed to
have today because you actually call him
old Dampier shanghaied extensively he
must have started what he'd written he's
not and did he have a publisher who how
did he had any first break into print
and put it with his maps and so forth
well there was a very astute man on the
London literary scene at this time a man
called James Knapton who I think latched
onto the the uniqueness of what don't be
had come back to England with them it's
often intrigued us at what stage of all
of this
did this man topia start actually
writing for publication but it's not the
natural thing that a pirate would start
to do
he became seduced away from just life as
a mere quest for gold to recording what
he was seeing in Ghent in such detail
with such power but when he got back to
England and obviously came into contact
with some of the leading thinkers of the
time that they must have persuaded him
that he had something so valuable it was
worth shaping for publication and James
Knapton who really published most of the
flood of narrative travel writing which
flowed from Dan cave which doubles the
catalyst he nurtured Dampier brought him
into print and made him a bestseller I
think the sad thing for Dampier was that
although he got paid ain't no one-off
fee there were no copyright laws at that
time so Deb you should have made like
you should have made more money from his
piracy he should have made more money
from his writing - do you have any a
clue about his education in in England
yes we do have some clues but it's
really a question of back fishing some
of the things he said later in life we
know that a certain stage he'd really
just become like a backpacker a hippie
give a scam off in Vietnam just
traveling for the sake of it and she got
very sick and she was all on his own by
the stage and he came across a French
priest missionary priest in a settler
who took him in and nursed him now don't
here could speak no French and the
priest could speak no English but they
managed to communicate with each other
by using Latin so I think he must have
had quite a good grounding in the
classics he probably went to what we
were poor one of our grammar schools
which were up and running at this time
and near to go to this you didn't need
to come from a particularly wealthy
background at all so I think he's that
he certainly had some formal education
and perhaps also some basic training
some basic science or maths we don't
know but they found the lesson very
interesting yes please
how did such a colorful character become
so unknown to us and how did you
discover him I take the second part of
the question first how did we discover
him um we were researching generally
about pirates and we kept coming across
these tantalizing references to this man
Dampier then frankly we haven't heard of
that he hit achieved things that are
literary fields and the field of natural
history or hydrography or whatever but
we could really find out very much and
then we got a further clue because we
found this reference to a portrait it's
pirate and hydrographer portrait hanging
in the National Portrait Gallery I
thought this is bizarre you know pirates
don't normally get their portraits
painted and look like poor old captain
cleared as I showed you there dangling
dead in his cage at her they're
generally depicted and we weren't alone
we had a look at the portrait and we
found a very powerful depiction of the
man of strong personality
the way he looks at Archer to you from
that portrait the book he's holding out
so proudly with the other thing earlier
the spine actually onlooker we thought
we really just have to find out a little
bit more about him we did we were amazed
at the extent of his achievements but
then you say you know absolutely
correctly well how come if you achieved
all these things do we not know about
him today
I think the answer is that you didn't
fade from view immediately you find that
for over a hundred years after his death
he was actually very well known that's
why people later on like cook like
courage they knew about him they
register work they praised him they
thought it was very important I think
the problems were poor old damp here
come when you get into the 19th century
of the Victorians arriving changing
moral attitudes here you had a man who
had very clearly started life in a
somewhat dubious way who happy
undoubtedly being a marauder on the high
seas therefore how could anything he
achieved or a written a bit of any real
value and there's even persisters you
know we found a reference in the local
archives from the village that Dampier
came from a big sort of argument round
about
1906 1907 when some people said look
this is an important character we must
put up a memorial to him in a local
church we find this battle between the
local bigwigs if I can call than that
with someone saying this is an outrage
you know the man was a rascal and a
pirate and he should have been hanged
and we're not going to commemorations so
I think you know the piracy taint really
pushed his the rise his reputation over
the horizon and it just dropped
completely from view don't you put any
other don't think so and the other point
was that he is brilliant certainly
emerges when you look at him across a
series of disciplines in a way like
Francis breaken said looking across
everything when things became more
specialized he was less known although
it was known for individual bits if you
look in histories of maritime marine
hydrography he's there if you look in
histories of Australia he's there as a
Discoverer but he only appears in little
bits in the places we've tried to bring
him together oh I think we'll save the
rest of our questions for the book
signing itself please join me in
thanking Diana and Michael presto
a pirate of exquisite mind is published
by Walker and company visit Walker books
comm for more information
next week public lives will be preempted
by our coverage of book Expo America in
two weeks